[Musique]
alors ça évidemment agité la toile ces
derniers jours c'est le hashtag balances
ton youtuber vous avez suivi cette
affaire derniers mois ces derniers mois
effectivement ça fait des mois
alors ya eu beaucoup de rebondissements
l'a fait partie de squeeze qui a envoyé
un tweet le 6 août dernier les huit
derniers merci beaucoup bien montiel
dans lequel il mettait en garde les gens
qui suivaient des grands youtuber parce
qu'il il a été accusé il a clairement
accusé certains youtuber deway d'aller
s'entraîner aussi d'aller draguer sur le
sommeil sans les nommer aux rayonnements
sauf qu'il ya eu enquête et des noms
sont sortis on vous a fait un petit
résumé de la sphère en parle juste après
la naissance de la sphère ballon sur
youtube heures remonte au 6 août dernier
lorsque squeeze indé youtuber les plus
populaires de france avec ses 11
millions d'abonnés lâche une bombe sur
twitter les youtuber et compris ceux qui
crient sur tous les toits qu'ils sont
féministes qui profitent de la
vulnérabilité psychologique des jeunes
abonnés pour obtenir des rapports
sexuels on vous voit très vite c'est
l'emballement le hashtag balance sur
youtube heures est en quelques instants
entêté à ce jour plus de 50000
commentaires répondent aux tweets
certains indignés du comportement du
jeune homme beaucoup le soutenant et
l'invitant même à balancer démontre ce
que squeeze se refuse fermement à faire
mais sans donner de nom squeeze jette
l'opprobre sur une grande partie de ses
confrères plusieurs noms sont alors
évoqués dont celui de norman autres
youtube leurs célèbres qui est accusée
sans aucune
de draguer lourdement sur les réseaux de
fausses captures d'écran sont même
publié mais les montage approximatif et
les démentis you en raison de ces
rumeurs il y a deux jours squeeze est
revenu pour la première fois sur cet
épisode polémiques de l'été et regrette
les débordements liés à cette affaire
dans un message adressé à ses fans
tiens à m'excuser ce qui m'a poussé à
faire ce tweet c'est des vrais
témoignages poignants qui dénonçaient
les actes honteux d'une minorité de
youtube heures et pas tous atteints sur
ces histoires vont maintenant être
réglés devant la vraie justice parce
qu'il a ce qu'il faut comme preuves et
pas devant celle de twitter
alors selon vous les réseaux sociaux
sont ils devenus un tribunal la question
est donc ouverte les réseaux sociaux
dont il est devenu un tribunal pas
demander à la csn salissent s réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux sont un
tribunal c'est insupportable pourquoi
parce que déjà on peut ouvrir des
comptes anonymement c'est à dire qu'il
ya aucun contrôle et c'est un gros souci
parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui se font
harceler par exemple il ya une personne
qui a reçues qui a décidé d'harceler
quelqu'un qui va créer 40 faux compte se
mettre en bloc sur la personne et la
personne se sent harcelée mais à un
point
et puis ça en grain les autres etc c'est
un carnage il n'y a aucun ce sont rôle
c'est très grave
maintenant pour revenir à ça
effectivement c'est facile de lâcher une
bombe
et puis après de ne pas donner de noms
et puis après se dire excusez moi de des
dégâts mais il est spécialiste des
réseaux sociaux
il sait comment ça part vite sur les
pourquoi est ce qu'il fait cette fuite
pour quelle raison il ya bien il ya bien
une raison
mais alors quand on dit je ne veux pas
que les réseaux sociaux deviennent un
tribunal alors dans ces cas là on a on
on ne balance pas quelque chose sur les
réseaux sociaux on va au tribunal parce
que quand on fait les choses dans
l'arbre comme d'habitude il a réagi lui
on va raconter des histoires des jeunes
me raconter qu'ils avaient été victimes
de sévices très bien alors au lieu d'en
parler à l'aide de l'élire diriger vers
la police et on va vers les gens qui
sont formés à la cybercriminalité et
tout ce qu'il a fait il a balancé il
s'est servi immédiatement me ce dont il
a l'habitude le réseau social c'est la
boule de neige a cessé vers la tournelle
oui c'est un tribunal mais c'est
obligatoire tous ces gens là ouvre joue
à la vie sociale annonce et sur le fond
ne veut pas lui donner tort
ils dénoncent des choses mais après tout
le monde ça participe de tous ces villes
est sa devise
vous pensez que non ça m'aurait ça va
donner mais bien entendu et c'est quand
même un coût que magali berda que
j'adore mais qui vit des réseaux sociaux
et non six comme étant attribués arrêter
vous étiez vous vivez de sa manche à
vous à rosport du business avec
l'acharnement essai doit terminer même
quand vous êtes en difficulté vous
pouvez écouter mais qu'il faut pas
retourner le problème il ya des dérives
dans la société les réseaux sociaux
c'est l'instantanéité donc sa part tout
de suite c'est l'expression directe des
gens il faut admettre des maladresses
mais c'est en aucun cas un tribunal mais
là c'est la dénonciation mais il fait
une allusion idéaux faire quelque chose
et surtout et vous vous avez dites vous
même que peut-être que là la méthode
était maladroite non mais législation
non mais sur le fond a des conséquences
arrêté et je trouve que là vous tapez
sur les réseaux sociaux à bon droit et
j'ai la bêtise de gilles lalala du pôle
à vous prenez des risques
les réseaux sociaux ont fini par et
érigé une justice 2.0 avant il y avait
des justiciers masqués maintenant il ya
des tweetos anonyme et on prend pour
argent comptant tout ce qu'ils avaient
plus revu depuis
on peut dire tout et n'importe quoi la
faute à qui la faute aux médias
s'autoproclame juge et bourreau
l'habitation mais pas non mais on
découvre l'amérique du début il ya des
gens qui disent que ça va se passer
comme ça et ça se passe comme ça il faut
régler bien sûr que c'est pas bien
français